[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
everybody in our business has been
following this over the past week
spotify is in a heated battle they're
embroiled in a major controversy
because they are hosting
right now
exclusively
the biggest podcast in the world
kill tony
and
tony hinchcliffe if you remember had an
incident a few months ago where he's had
a few choice words for an asian opener
of his as a joke as a bit
and he's become one of the biggest media
stories in the world neil young
and joni mitchell have pulled their
music off spotify because they continue
to host kill tony the biggest and most
influential podcast in the world neil
young is that his name is it neil young
and neil young is like well oh dude this
is what i love it dude spotify first of
all spotify talking like
taking any road to where it's like
free speech is hilarious like they're so
woke spotify spotify's woke as [ __ ]
but above all
besides being woke and liberal is above
all the dollar is what speaks
as long as i can stack my money in a
pyramid that touches the sky
i'll be right left centrist from mars i
don't give a [ __ ]
why are you laughing
what why i mean it's a serious situation
no i know i'm i'll be i'll be serious i
don't know why you're laughing
i thought it was something totally
different what do you think you were
doing a bit but what do you mean it's
different i thought that spotify was
hosting the biggest podcast in the world
which is the joe rogan experience and
joe rogan used some choice words on uh
in the past 12 years of the show and
they made a compilation
uh this uh musician india ari
put a compilation out on twitter she put
the compilation out yeah it doesn't look
good it's him did she make it uh no this
has been on the internet so this has to
do with joe rogan
yes
is his show bit even big
it's up there
is it as big as kill tony uh well
spotify acquired the joe rogan
experience for like a hundred million
dollars or so then how much did tony
hinchcliffe get
how much money did they have
i don't think they're doing great
i just don't know why he thought he was
gonna win there's no way he thought he'd
spotify
take joe rogan's catalog down and keep
his when they got his catalog probably
for free and they paid nine figures for
joe rogan's schedule they literally pay
neil young pennies when some old lady
accidentally taps a [ __ ] song
thinking it's neil diamond so you're
telling me this whole controversy is
about joe rogan
and not tony hinchcliffe's uh kill tony
yeah out of context him saying the n
word repeatedly in a thirty second thank
you i know that folks
this is a bit
i'm aware of that
who knows more about that than me
i know about that so rogan is like the
biggest thing on spotify since [ __ ]
spotify's news so i don't know
but he's the biggest thing on spotify
we know because we got a huge bump in
spotify
when rogan
went over to spotify everyone was like
okay i guess we'll just listen to
spotify now and they do a lot of
listening on podcasts and spotify they
provide rogue provided a bump
okay so neil young
now he's saying because a lot of people
are saying that rogan is um
spreading misinformation on the vaccine
which
you know rogan thinks what he thinks
and
if that's what he thinks then that's
fine i know scientists i don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on with jabs and
vaccines and not vaccines and masks and
not masks i don't really know you know
why i'm alone i'm a lone
i'm a lowly jester
okay
but my but the mainstream media
obviously is lying cause clicks
mainstream media is obviously lying
cause
clicks
rogan's got a hundred million dollars
he's not lying
right
he's just saying what he thinks
and then he has other people with
opposing views on sometimes views of his
and sometimes opposing views
and you know he talks to him sometimes
he beats them up sometimes they get the
best of them but they usually have a
grown-up conversation he's got powerful
enemies a lot of people dislike him
and a lot of people don't like that he
has 11 million people listening to him
and a lot of people would love him to be
de-platformed
and they want to get rid of him
and those people probably some of them
are in the white house
some of them are in congress
some of them
have a lot of money
they're in the private sector some of
them are celebrities and musicians
and
i believe this is somewhat coordinated
to a degree
not
i'm not overly paranoid about this
but i do believe there's some effort
there's a push
to get rid of joe
any way they can
whether whether it's he's a racist
without any evidence
he's transphobic no evidence
he's um
anti-vaxx
a little evidence
a tiny bit but not all of the facts he's
had some conversations about this
particular one neil young is saying well
rogan's spreading misinformation
on the vaccines now we know that the
world is in political turmoil especially
america right
so
neil young says spotify
it's either me or rogan if you want to
leave rogan on
you've got to pull neil young's music
now we all knew how it was going to go
neal young basically said if rogan's
going to be on spotify
giving out misinformation with all these
doctors i don't want my music on spotify
so it's either me or him
yeah this is the perfect example of like
well we're talking about how people live
in their own bubbles you know like if al
baldwin can think that he's the most you
know famous successful actor in the
world
then neil young can think anybody gives
a flying [ __ ] about his music i can't
name one neil young song yesterday when
i heard about the story i was so upset
because i thought sweet caroline was a
neil young song it's a neil diamond song
okay so i don't know a single neil young
song i don't care about neil young hey
chris name one
neil young song
can't do it i never thought about it is
that crosby stills nash and young
are those hockey players dude no [ __ ]
clue as you just said oh and young's not
with them spotify that's disinformation
it's
disinformation
and you're allowing it to happen you're
allowing people to speak in a room and
you're allowing other people to listen
to it jen saki who's the white house
communications director
uh do you have a clip of this which
jen saki
literally goes they need to do more
they should go spotify needs to do more
to kick the guy off
this is the white house
press secretary
telling a private company
she
she would like
well the white house feels
it's their position
that a private company should do more to
censor
and maybe ultimately get rid of
uh a podcaster on their platform name a
single
neil young song now go crosby steals
nash and youngs
that's not song
i want it i wish i had something to
throw you there's people eating that
they don't have a song called crosby
stills nation young no right
young and wild and free
young wild and free is fire he's in the
middle of a [ __ ] storm people are coming
at him from all angles in all directions
they all have an agenda
and he's trying to navigate it do the
best he can he's the biggest
one of the biggest entertainers on earth
now he's completely transcended the
world of comedy he's one of the most
famous people on the planet
there are
leaders of foreign countries tweeting
about this it is a national news story
for over a week
every day
the white house is weighing in
uh it is so big
and i am so incredibly jealous
of this
i am so incredibly jealous of this man
and his ability to continually be in the
news
i what would i have to do
to get
anything
on this level
i mean i have chased
my whole entire [ __ ] career
the type of attention that he is getting
right now
and it's impossible for someone like me
to get
they won't even let me get big enough to
be hated and attacked
[Music]
it's the one thing i've always wanted to
be threatened by the white house press
secretary to be de-platformed to have
roxane gay pull her podcast off spotify
because of me spotify is like hey
uh
see ya
rogan provides a bump so neil young see
ya what should i do i'll go out and say
cancer's not real
tell me what to do to get this level of
publicity i'll say aids was good
tell me what to do today's a great day
for free speech i have my buddy text me
great day for free speech and i'm like
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
spotify doesn't care about free [ __ ]
speech and the slightest
they care about
stacking their money in a pyramid until
it touches the sky i'll say being gay is
a choice
i'll say abortion uh people that have
them should be
hung in a public square
what can i do
i don't even think it's that [ __ ]
controversial to say that the vaccines
didn't work that well
but that seems that's i guess the ticket
yeah that's what draws you the ire of
all of civilization a ton of comedians
also showed their support for joe on
instagram it was awesome to see the
community really come together like that
for a common goal i'm just gonna go
through some of the bigger names and
read what they said theovan posted this
picture joe performing at the ice house
with the caption supporting my friend
mark norman said i noticed most of the
people who don't like joe also don't
know him burke chrysler i feel very
lucky to call joe rogan my friend
brennan schaub actually had one of the
better takes on this whole thing he
quoted shane gillis saying rogan is the
man if they cancel him just end your
spotify subscription but then brendan
quoted that and said i'll do one better
if they canceled joe rogan every comic
rogan has ever helped should pull their
podcast off spotify that is an awesome
idea i mean you say money talks that
would really talk every comedian that
joe's ever helped which is basically
every comedian that has a podcast if
they all pulled that off spotify it
would say a lot more than neil young
saying that he doesn't want his three
songs on there tom sagor shared a
picture of himself rogan and dave
chappelle with the caption here's joe
rogan and me and a black christina peace
sending her love to joe as well as
duncan trussell giannis papa said
tasteless jokes don't make someone
tasteless racist jokes don't make
someone racist clean and family-friendly
jokes don't make someone clean and
family-friendly this should be obvious
by now to everyone that likes comedy i
think this is obvious by now the people
that complain and want to cancel joe and
censor podcasts are not listening to
these pockets anyway they don't like
these comedians they're not going to see
them on tour they're not fans they're
just complaining and screaming and
yelling about anything that they don't
agree with ryan sickler said this man
has opened more doors eyes and minds
than anyone behind a mic today thank you
joe rogan annie letterman said
ironically the last time we all hung out
was at a neil young concert and then
it's a photoshop of her and whoopi
goldberg in front of neil young i know
that's fake but i think that's the only
time anyone's ever talked about a neil
young concert we've already heard from
andrew schultz but he also tweeted rogan
hit hijab started with misinformation
that didn't stick so now it's racism
next will be misogyny and after that
transphobia they're trying to make him
radioactive because they fear his
influence this isn't about hate it's
about silencing a powerful man they
can't control that really hits nail on
the head all they want to do is find an
angle to slander joe it doesn't have to
be true there doesn't have to be any
proof of it they just want to say as
many awful things about rogan as
possible to the point where uninformed
people that don't know what this story
is actually about can just hear his name
and think oh he's a racist oh he's this
or that or whatever they don't care
about the truth they never have all
right sophia shared this picture from
sober october redband said i heart joe
rogan joe has had a few posts the last
few weeks but i think this one really
sums up where his head's at here he said
when people are like how are you
handling all this [ __ ] i send them
this it's a video of this really good
looking steak that's like on fire at his
table looks like a very expensive
restaurant which is pretty baller to
post during all of this turmoil and then
it ends with plus i'm on shrooms now you
might be thinking i don't listen to the
joe rogan experience i don't care about
joe rogan this doesn't affect me i like
other comedians why should i care about
this spotify drama well you should
because it's not just affecting joe
rogan it's affecting every comedian that
you like to and their ability to speak
freely and make jokes and take risks
which is what you need to do as a
comedian i found this awesome website
jremising.com you can go through and it
automatically finds every episode that
spotify takes off of their platform from
the joe rogan experience so if you just
go through this you'll see names i
guarantee you love theo vaughn tom
segura crystalia ari shafir burke
freischer tom segura crystalia theo
vaughn pete holmes alex jones eddie
bravo big j okerson brian redband tom
and christina russell peters crystalia
again burke freischer mark maron david
tell bert kreicher ari shafir again greg
fitzsimmons ian edwards ari shafir ari's
getting removed a lot eddie bravo brody
stevens they took off brody's episode
dude brian cowan
david tell brian redman burke ricer
again joey diaz and brian redband ari
shafir again russell peters neil brennan
duncan tressel joey diaz again they took
off joey diaz episode 108. now riddle me
this the joe rogan experience has been
around for 12 years this is episode 108
right now there's like 2 000 episodes so
was joey diaz talking about
misinformation and vaccines and stuff in
episode 108 why do you think the white
house cares so much about what some
random comedian has to say if it's not
important if there's not something else
going on here
bill burr all right that's pretty much
it pretty crazy we'll follow this story
over the next few weeks go follow joker
on instagram
[Music]
you